all right if you've always dreamed of
driving your car on a racetrack now's
your chance to do it and it's for a
great cause Paulette Anderson executive
director of Speedway Children's
Charities joins us to talk about laps
for charity at Las Vegas Motor Speedway
it is great to have you with us for an
event coming up this weekend yes thank
you so much for letting me come on and
promote this event to your fans your
viewers so this Sunday January 29th from
8 A.M to 4 P.M we have what's called
laps for charity where people will take
their personal vehicles and they will
drive it around the Super Speedway so I
mean if your car is street legal and you
have a license 18 and older you can
drive the Super Speedway so we have all
kinds of cars we even had funeral
parlors bring up horses before we've had
food trucks we we see it all on the
speedway but again if it's if it can
keep up at 75 miles per hour on the
track and you have that license you can
do it but you must be 18 or older and if
you choose to bring your family which
who wouldn't right just keep in mind
though six and olds are for kid is to be
in the car yes and not to drive though
they can't drive uh no they can leave
the Fisher Price home okay uh this is an
event that's very popular you can have
people coming back year after year we do
it is so exciting we have over 300
people pre-registered right now and so
many of them come back year after year
which means they're having a great time
so you have 10 car vehicles go on the
track at one time we have the lvm
speedway sorry the Speedways Pace card
the 10 vehicles and then they do five to
seven laps okay and when they're
finished they'll come off they'll get a
free photo that they can download
afterwards and it's just so much fun it
raises a lot of money and it's what's
really important is it's one price per
vehicle so if you pay 75 or 100 for your
your time to go out there if you have
four people in the car with you it's
just that one price which is amazing
stuff your friends in the car and have
some fun yeah seat belts and all for
let's tell people about children's
Speedway Charities yes I would love to
thank you so Speedway Children's
Charities we raise money all year long
and then in December we award grants to
different Children's Charities in the
community that help kids in need so in
December we gave a half a million
dollars away to uh so 63 groups
including Nevada partnership for
homeless youth goody two shoes eye care
for kids candlelighters so we basically
raise the money and then we just put it
back in the community so it's so
important to raise money at labs for
charity because the more money we have
the more grants we don't want to turn
people away in December so we want to
just keep raising lots of money so we
can give it to the kids in need well
thanks for all the good you're doing in
the community I want to let people know
where they can sign up for the event
let's take a look laps for charity yes
yes at Las Vegas Motor Speedway this
Sunday from noon until four you can get
information by going to our website we
have a link and then your website is
Speedway charities.org Las Vegas and yes
noon to four we have car clubs reserved
eight to noon so yes noon to four VIPs
general admission love to have you help
us raise money to help kids in need